[Música]
recuerdo cuando los lunes me causaban la
misma sensación de terror como cuando
estás solo en casa ya medianoche
escuchas el ruido de cristales que se
rompen
tan solo pensar en esos lunes de mi vida
me provoca escalofríos en esta vida he
tenido distintos tipos de situaciones
laborales con jefes sin jefes jefes
buenos malos y muy muy muy malos y no
puedo olvidar la relación más larga jefe
subordinado de mi vida ya que fue la
peor de todas
en ese entonces yo trabajaba en un
trabajo que me encantaba hacía cosas que
realmente disfrutaba tenía la
oportunidad de ser creativa tenía la
oportunidad de convivir con colegas que
realmente eran fantásticos y
espectaculares pero bueno bien dicen que
en la vida uno no puede tenerlo todo y
el destino me cobró la factura enviando
me al peor jefe de mí
recuerdo cuando los lunes era llamada
para rendir cuentas a la oficina de esta
innombrable persona
y bueno yo entraba a su oficina después
de unos incómodos minutos en los cuales
ella me observaba detenidamente a los
ojos como comunicándose con mi yo animal
tratando de decirme este es mi
territorio entonces empezaba el rey
cuando las cosas se alejaban de lo que
ella creía que era lo correcto dejaba
muy en claro qué bueno las cosas estaban
mal sin dejar claro porque estaban mal o
qué podíamos hacer para mejorarlas
la única pregunta que me hacía era si la
responsabilidad fuera un pastel de qué
tamaño es tu rival
difícil cuestionamiento con
maquiavélicas intenciones al final bueno
les seguía la corriente y salía de su
oficina muy muy frustrada muy molesta y
ustedes creen que yo era eficiente por
supuesto que no y tampoco lo eran los
que me rodeaban esta persona era muy
famosa por sus frases célebres
además de la de la rebanada de pastel
tenemos la de no hace falta tener más de
dos dedos de frente para entender eso o
también tenemos la de que está más
temida de todas chiquita quiero mucho tu
cabeza pero quiero más a la mía y si una
de las dos tiene que rodar no va a ser
la mía
sin embargo bueno después de un tiempo
aprendí
que bueno a través de inclusive estas
patológicas relaciones uno puede
aprender cosas uno puede desarrollar
habilidades como la residencia y el
autocontrol y no sólo eso descubrí cuál
es mi misión en la vida salía al mundo y
decidí dedicarme a recopilar las
historias de los peores jefes del mundo
para erradicarlos no más rebanada de
pastel no más cabeza rodando en medio
del pavor cuando puede haber personas
felices haciendo trabajos que realmente
disfruten
también a través de estos años he tenido
la oportunidad de trabajar en distintos
países a lo largo de todo el continente
desde canadá hasta argentina con
personas de distintas culturas europeos
asiáticos africanos de medio oriente
latinos por supuesto y en muchas
conversaciones que he tenido he
encontrado un elemento en común existe
una insatisfacción con la relación que
tenemos con nuestros gentes
[Música]
y bueno compilando todas estas historias
y todas estas anécdotas al mismo estilo
que el doctor frankenstein me pude
imaginar lo que sería ese monstruo que
representa el peor jefe del mundo y
bueno quiero agradecer a mis sobrinos
antiques talentosísimo y que logró
plasmar en un dibujo del terror que
puede provocar este personaje
pero bueno porque es esto importante
porque hablar de los jefes qué impacto
tienen en las organizaciones
les voy a presentar algunos datos
interesantes que han sido obtenidos a
través de investigaciones realizadas por
instituciones de alto prestigio como
harvard business review stanford forms
que nos hablan un poco acerca de este
impacto
el 65% de los empleados preferirían un
nuevo jefe sobre un aumento de suelo o
sea no me des más dinero quítame a este
tipo por favor
tres de cada cuatro empleados reportan
que la peor y más estresante parte de su
trabajo es lidiar con su jefe o sea no
son los resultados los indicadores no
son los clientes son los jefes
[Música]
el 58 por ciento de los jefes no han
recibido ningún entrenamiento acerca de
cómo ser jefes
por lo general una persona es buena
haciendo su trabajo y es promovida y de
repente un día es jefe
pero el pse de talentos que requerimos
para ser exitosos como contribuidores
individuales es muy distinto al set de
talentos que necesitamos para ser buenos
jefes y muchas veces este aprendizaje
sucede de una forma muy intuitiva qué
significa eso es un poco como cómo
aprendemos a ser padres yo no sé si a
los que tienen hijos les pase como a mí
pero a veces yo abro la boca y no soy yo
la que está hablando es mi mamá
el 89 por ciento de los jefes cree que
sus empleados renuncian porque alguien
les ofrece más dinero pero la realidad
sólo el 12% renuncian por este motivo
58 las personas confían más en cualquier
extraño que sus jefes cualquier
desconocido es mejor que sus jefes
79 por ciento de las personas renuncian
por una falta de reconocimiento y en
especial por una falta de reconocimiento
por parte de sus jefes de hecho se ha
encontrado que el reconocimiento es el
factor principal de lo que una persona
requiere de su jefe y supera otros
elementos como inclusive como el sueldo
la capacitación las promociones etcétera
los malos jefes no solamente producen
empleados infelices los malos jefes
también los enferman porque las personas
que tienen malos jefes tienen un 30% más
de probabilidades de desarrollar
enfermedades cardíacas por supuesto ante
tanto estrés esto es bastante
comprensible
y finalmente los malos jefes también
cuestan dinero a las organizaciones
porque porque provocan en sus empleados
comportamientos destructivos
por ejemplo provocan que la gente haga
su trabajo más lento cometen errores a
propósito
mienten se reportan enfermos cuando en
realidad no lo están como yo muchas
veces lo quise hacer todos los lunes
inclusive boicotean al jefe al final del
día tenemos personas que están haciendo
no todo lo que pueden están haciendo lo
mínimo para que no los corren
les quiero platicar algunas cosas que he
compilado acerca de qué hacen estos
jefes qué cosas hacen y cuáles son las
quejas más de la gente con la que yo he
conversado una vez agreden pero no
necesariamente es una agresividad
directa muchas veces es una agresividad
pasiva lo cual es a veces peor es una
agresividad que se disfraza debajo del
sarcasmo debajo de las indirectas de las
que dibujan para que me entiendas pedro
y esta agresividad causa mucho mayor
confusión
son manipuladores también o manipulan
usan las palabras lindas usan el
reconocimiento pero en realidad la
persona no les importa nos gustan como
una estrategia para conseguir lo que
quieren
saludan con sombrero ajeno son astutos
políticas políticos en realidad buscan
venderse bien dentro y fuera de las
organizaciones a costa inclusive de su
equipo de trabajo
también mienten eso es una conducta
bastante recurrente y esto es bastante
grave porque creen que se salen con la
suya al mentir pero la verdad es que no
es así la gente los lee cuadran
versiones la gente se da cuenta que
están mintiendo y bueno al final se
desmorona la confianza culpan a su
equipo de lo que sale mal y no se
involucran para generar una solución y
finalmente no son congruentes
es decir exigen lo que ellos mismos no
están dispuestos a dar
y ahora sí que podemos hacer para
resolver esto
alfred nobel fue el inventor de la
dinamita en 1888 un periódico público
alfred nobel el mercader de la muerte ha
fallecido
al freno había muerto el periódico se
había equivocado porque había muerto el
hermano de alto sin embargo este titular
pues causó una gran impresión en afa y
él pues no quería ser recordadas a
partir de esto decide dar gran parte de
su fortuna para la creación de la
fundación nobel que es la fundación que
hasta el día de hoy otorga diversos
premios como el premio nobel de la paz
me encanta contar esta historia al grupo
de jefes y luego preguntarles cómo
deseas que tu equipo te recuerde cuando
tú no estés qué cosas quieres que la
gente diga de ti
y he hecho esta pregunta en pacientes de
personas en distintos países y aunque
las respuestas son bastante variadas al
final todo se centra en un mismo
concepto todos quieren ser recordados
como buenas personas
todos tienen esa intención
david brooks ha clasificado las virtudes
en dos tipos a las primeras les llama
las virtudes de currículo que son cosas
como la fortaleza la perseverancia el
ser competitivo son ese tipo de
características de las cuales las
personas hablan en una entrevista de
trabajo
y por otro lado tenemos las virtudes que
él llama de elogio son aquellas
características de las cuales las
personas hablarían en un funeral cosas
mucho más trascendentes como la gratitud
como la colaboración y como la
generosidad y se ha encontrado que estas
tres características son clave para en
realidad lograr tener buenos jefes que
sí son lo suficientemente buenos podrán
convertirse en genuinos líderes
pero como desarrollar esto yo realmente
creo que
casi todas las personas salvo algunas
excepciones parte desde una intención
positiva simplemente falta alinear sus
comportamientos para que lo que dicen y
hacen realmente tenga el impacto que
ellos desean creo que hay muchos jefes
con buenas intenciones porque no saben
cómo hacer las cosas no saben qué es lo
que es realmente valioso
que puede ser un jefe para demostrar
estos estas tres virtudes para demostrar
gratitud una herramienta fabulosa es la
retroalimentación pero no aquella que
sea como regaño cuando las cosas salen
mal no la retroalimentación positiva la
que se da ante los logros la que sea
para reconocer talentos para reconocer
fortalezas esa que son esta esa que es
puntual esa que se puede dar de forma
espontánea por ejemplo un oye qué bien
manejaste al cliente en la junta a pesar
de que venía molesto vi que se fue
bastante tranquilo o uno oye gracias por
entregar los reportes a tiempos sé que
este mes el trabajo ha sido pesadísimo y
en verdad agradezco el esfuerzo extra
la ciencia nos dice que las personas
necesitan reconocimiento y además es
gratis y aún así hay personas que
piensan pues porque habría que
reconocerle si para eso les pagamos pues
porque funciona porque está comprobado
que funciona y porque somos seres
humanos
como podemos mostrar colaboración al ser
jefes es muy simple simplemente ser
parte del equipo y ser congruentes qué
significa esto significa que antes en
tiempos de crisis me levanto las mangas
y hago lo que sea necesario si el equipo
debe quedarse tarde para entregar un
proyecto me quedo con el equipo si exijo
que el equipo sea puntual soy puntual
hago lo que realmente puedo hacer y no
solo lo que creo que corresponde por el
rango que yo te hace algunos años estaba
trabajando con un grupo de líderes en
una empresa inmensa petrolera en su
corporativo para latinoamérica que está
en brasil y a la reunión entre el
presidente de latinoamérica lo primero
que hace es en el centro del salón se
agacha y recoge un pedazo de basura que
estaba tirado y lo tira al bote 2
si deseamos ver ciertos comportamientos
en nuestros equipos necesitamos ser
congruentes no importa el récord
y finalmente la generosidad que para mí
es el más importante de los tres cómo
podemos ser generosos al ser jefes un
jefe es generoso al compartir
información al compartir su conocimiento
al compartir su propia experiencia un
jefe es generoso al dedicar tiempo al
escuchar al explicar al corregir los
ciudades generosos comparten recursos la
computadora más rápida el café de mejor
calidad los viajes a los destinos
deseables los jefes generosos realmente
logran transformar a las personas qué
tensión descubrió que para ser un buen
jefe lo más más importante es ser como
un buen maestro tener las habilidades de
un maestro y creo que no hay mayor
ejemplo de generosidad que la
generosidad de los maestros
yo les aseguro que si ahorita piensan en
el jefe más valioso que han tenido
probablemente esa persona no sea
perfecta seguramente habrá cometido sus
errores pero yo les aseguro que esa
persona logró que ustedes se
convirtieran en una mejor persona a
través de esa relación
y bueno quiero cerrar esta conversación
aplicando uno de los tres conceptos me
voy a basar en el concepto de la
gratitud y quiero cerrar agradeciendo a
todos los terribles jefes del mundo a
todos esos monstruos con los que me he
cruzado por el camino de forma directa o
indirecta porque sus lecciones han sido
muy valiosos porque los aprendizajes han
sido muy importantes y creo que esta
lucha vale la pena seguir y yo les
prometo que voy a seguir viviendo hasta
erradicar al último jefe monstruo
convirtiéndolos en personas agradecidas
colaborativas y generosas muchas gracias
tú
[Música]